David Maxwell I scored the zeroth
percentile for conscientiousness in the
84th for neuroticism how do i improve
these scores well okay so the first
thing David you might want to think
about is like if all of your scores were
low then there's some possibility that
you're being too hard on yourself and
what I would recommend then is get a
couple of friends to fill out the
questionnaire for for you to describe
you and then see if first of all if
there's any agreement see if they've
they are easier on you than you are
yourself so but let's assume that you
are rather low in conscientiousness the
next question would be well how young
are you because younger people tend to
be lower in conscientiousness so if
you're like 16 well that's low but it's
not catastrophic if you're like 40 and
you're not depressed then 0th is you
know that's low anyways if you are that
low in conscientiousness one of the
things I would recommend is a make a
plan and B learn how to use a schedule a
calendar and do it badly to begin with
like an electronic calendar like Google
Calendar that's the best thing I know of
to improve conscientiousness make a plan
so that you've got something to aim at
and use a scheduler and maybe you have
to you know talk to someone to help keep
you on track now the other question
would be do you have other personality
traits that are really high like
openness because if you're really high
and openness then it might be that
you're more inclined towards being
motivated by spontaneous interest and in
the artistic direction and if you're
really high an extraversion then you're
going to be motivated by being around
people you know so it also may be that
in order to be conscientious about
something you have to pick a domain that
you're suited to like socializing or
artistic endeavor and try to work on
being conscientious in those domains so
that's it